when you weren't number one anymore what
how hard was that or had you been so
used to it that you were kind of well
like you said you know you had
you were giving yourself the permission
to lose yeah I mean but was it still you
know was that still that kind of you
know
fighting Eye of the Tiger things yeah I
think that that carried through
especially with that sort of second
second coming of of life not my skating
but but the skating's popularity in the
late 90s early 2000s
um yeah for sure I was I was
of the same mindset where I was just
like all right I'm gonna
I'm gonna focus in I'm gonna do the you
know I have all the I have a little I
had strategy yeah in competition a lot
of skaters they just they just throw it
out there yeah whatever comes comes and
and um I always wanted to be a little
more calculated but uh but yeah I think
so and then
for me uh in 1999
I had already sort of
decided subconsciously that I didn't
want to compete anymore and I knew that
that sort of chapter of my life was
going to come to an end even though
I was still doing well and and I was
getting a lot of endorsements and things
I just it was I was burning out I was
done I'd done it 20 years but yeah and
that was the year that um I finally did
a 900 and that was the the big
um X Games best trick event and
I didn't realize it at the time but then
I afterwards I thought oh that was my
exit from competition yeah that's that's
the best moment I could possibly hope
for yeah and it came spontaneously and
that was a good out wow when I mean
explain for people what an I mean it's
the revolutions what a 900 is uh yeah
it's it's basically a two and a half
somersault in the air on your skateboard
you leave the ramp and spin around two
and a half times and come back down the
same side of the ramp yeah and when you
say that I mean had you done it before
you know before you did it in
competition and you weren't were you
thinking I'm gonna spin around two and a
half times or uh did you just over
rotate and pull it off you know I mean
the evolution of that was uh in 1985
um
there was a trick called a mctwist I
didn't admit that uh it Mike McGill did
he had made that up the year before and
it's a one and a half Spin and so I was
skating this ramp it was actually a lot
bigger than most ramps in that time but
it allowed you to get more air time yeah
and I figured out how to spend 720 on
that ramp and then the next stage of
that would be
with the 900 but but the 900 is is a big
step forward because you are blind to
your Landing Zone twice ah and that
changes everything in terms of your
comfortability and also just your
spatial awareness like everything is it
just changes so and your chance of being
horribly injured too are very good yeah
yeah so I started trying it a few years
later but I just couldn't figure out the
right spinning technique
um and then
uh I would say somewhere around 1994 I
started to get a little better at it and
actively try yeah and then I got hurt uh
in 1996 I broke a rib and I finally
tried to make it I was I had all the
pieces Oh I thought and I've put it on
the wall and then I was leaning too far
forward I broke a rib and that was sort
of like okay maybe it's not possible
right
um and there are a few other people
trying it so fast forward to that X
Games
I only had one trick in mind to do that
was my best trick at the time not a 900.
it was it was a version of a 720 and I
made that halfway into the event
so I had nowhere to go right and then
the the on-site announcer Who had who
was a skater and knew my history I was
like let's see one of those 900 attempts
he literally said that and I thought to
myself oh man like not that tricky sorry
rib and then I I tried it and
around my third or fourth attempt I
really tried it just to show the crowd
what an attempt would look like yeah and
then somewhere around the third or
fourth attempt there was something
clicked that I was getting a consistent
spin I was getting a consistent speed
and that had not happened before it was
usually like one out of five attempts
where all systems go this was every time
I did it everything was working yeah and
so around the eighth or ninth attempt I
just tried to make it again I thought if
I'm gonna break my rib again
it might as well be in this scenario
yeah and I did the same thing I fell
forward but I was okay I see and so then
on my next attempt I figured out how to
shift my weight more to my back foot mid
spin yeah which was the that was it that
was the that was the Tipping Point yeah
and literally a Tipping Point yeah and
then when I came down I fell backwards
and so when I fell backwards I thought
oh just split the difference yeah yeah
and I made the next one wow
um and that was I mean that that night
you know in terms of the sort of
the excitement level and and for me the
obsession of that trick I was either
gonna make it that night or they were
gonna take me out an ambulance yeah like
there was no just there was no quitting
now this trick when you're when you're
attempting this over all those years are
you with other people or are you trying
to keep it secret no we were doing it
like I think that there's a there's a
false narrative that we were all trying
in secret we're trying to be the first
and and there were only I mean at the
time there were only a handful of actual
vert half pipes yeah so the verse yeah
we're all skating together and and there
were actually other events that happened
prior to X Games that were they had a
900 challenge at one event where there
was a half pipe that they were doing
some exhibitions on but then the shoe
company said okay we're given 10 grand
to whoever can do a 900 and so there
were about five of us that were just
trying it yeah aimlessly yeah yeah
now is that is that something because I
don't know add that much about
is that something now that a lot of
people can do no
um but but they have gone further so now
that we have the bigger ramps and we
have a new generation that that has Come
Through Skateboarding knowing that 900s
are possible right
um Tom Shar who's one of the best fruit
skaters in the world he did a 1080 when
he was young wow
um and then uh Mitchy Brusco who is a
young and they're young they're they're
all close to 30 now but yeah um he did a
1260. oh wow and no one I mean
a couple people did 1080s I would say
about
maybe 10 people have done 900s yeah
three people did 1080s one person has
done a 1260. wow that's where we're at
what's gonna limit it I mean you said
you know the ramps are higher is there
any difference in technology or is it
just people being brave enough to know
that it's well I think that have the
mindset I think that something comes
with knowing that this is possible when
you've already started yeah that someone
has already reached this goal so you can
get there that that's helped me in the
past but also that the resources I mean
now you can try your first 900 into a
foam pit lucky kids yeah I didn't have
any phone pits I had hard concrete yeah
you should you should hang around the
foam pit and just tell okay you're a
bunch of horses I did try I tried to
learn variations of the 900 into foam
pits but didn't work out for me and what
where you just uh like a different grab
yeah yeah you know or or different style
doing it and and even though I maybe
could Land one in the fun pit I could
never translate that to the action I see
I see